[Musique]
aujourd'hui on part à la découverte de
manie lesamo une commune d'environ 9400
habitants elle fait partie de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Eveline elle est située aux portes du
parc naturel régional de la Haute Vallée
de Chevreuse elle est constituée de cet
amameau aujourd'hui on va découvrir
ensemble ses habitants ses producteurs
locaux mais aussi son histoire et on
part tout de suite à la rencontre de
Pierre Adrien d'ouvet le gérant des
étends de Romainville un lieu dédié à la
pêche à la
[Musique]
truite
pierre Adrien bonjour bonjour alors vous
êtes le gérant des éttins de Romainville
quel est le concept de ce lieu le
concept du lieu réside dans le fait
qu'on puisse venir passer un moment dans
la nature au bord de l'eau et les mains
dans les poches quasiment puisque on
peut tout louver sur place ou acheter
tout ce qu'il faut pour réparer son
matériel qu'on a pas utilisé depuis des
années et donc on est là pour vendre du
bon temps et du plaisir aux gens et en
essayant de leur apporter tout ce qu'il
peuvent avoir besoin lors de cette
journée au bord de l'eau donc ils
peuvent louer canne à pêche hameçon ils
peuvent louer les canne à pêches les
épuisettes les bouriches pour stocker
les poissons acheter les appass sur
place ils peuvent aussi louer un jeu de
pétanque d'accord ou des chaises pour
pouvoir s'assoir au bord de l'eau et
puis dans le parc il y a des espaces de
pique-nique qui sont aménagés pour
pouvoir faire un petit barbecue en
famille ou entre amis vous avez C si
étanss au total qu'est-ce qu'on peut
pêcher dans dans vos étanss alors dans
nos étanss on est il trouve toute espèce
de poisson qui peut y avoir dans un étan
donc il y a principalement la pêche
c'est de la pêche à la truite et à la
carpe d'accord on pêche la carpe en
noquil on remet tous les poissons à
l'eau les truites on peut les prélever
pour les consommer ou les remettre à
l'eau pour les pêcher uniquement pour le
plaisir aussi alors est-ce que vous
pouvez me faire un petit cours express
pour m'apprendre à pêcher ah bah oui
ououi bien sûr oui oui vous avez combien
d'heures devant
vous non non mais on va essayer de faire
ça en une demi-heure une heure des fois
ça marche très bien des fois ça marche
pas du tout ça dépendra des poissons
malure heureusement parce qu'on a beau
être bon pêcheur c'est pas pour ça qu'on
attraperea du poisson bon ben après si
j'attrape rien c'est pas très grave mais
on va essayer de faire en sorte hein
c'est parti on y va c'est
[Musique]
parti alors là le mouvement pour mettre
le la canne enfin le fil dans l'eau du
moins oui parce qu'on évite de mettre la
canne dans l'eau hein sinon ça fait peur
au poisson et le mouvement pour mettre
la canne dans l'eau c'est un mouvement
de balancier avec le fil en fait
pour que le fil aille le plus loin
possible ou du moins là où on le
[Musique]
souhaite alors pour les poissons qu'on
pêche qui attrape l'hameçon et qui
ensuite sont relâcher ça leur fait pas
mal ça leur fait rien c'est alors quand
on pêche en en noquile c'est-à-dire
qu'on veut quand on veut remettre les
poissons à l'eau en bonne santé et
vivant bien sûr on pêche avec des
hameçons qui n'ont pas d'Ardillon
l'ardillon c'est la petite pointe qui
rebique qui revient en dessous la pointe
principale de l'hameçon d'accord donc on
va écraser cet ardillon on va pêcher ave
des hameçons qui sont directement sans
ardillion pour justement que ça fasse
comme une aiguille en fait et qu'au
moment où on enlève l'ameçon ça
cicatrise très facilement puisque la
peau la chair n'a pas été arracher
[Musique]
ou
là c une
pêcheelle après cette session pêche
direction le garde manger de manie
lesamoau un magasin qui vend uniquement
des produits fermiers et locaux c'est
notamment ici qu'Olivier marcouillou
berger itinérant dans la vallée de
Chevreuse
vériette vous avez un troupeau de
combien de de moutons de brebis alors
j'en ai bah là j'ai 400 brebis on a 500
têtes à peu près ouais 500 moutons et
donc grâce à ce troupeau de 400 500
bêtes environ vous produisez des
rillettes et aussi de du jambon d'agneau
donc en fait mon idée c'est de produire
la fertilité et de la biodiversité et en
coproduit on a la viande des agneaux et
elles sont à quoi vos rillettes alors
c'est des donc j'ai mis sur l'étiquette
riette de béliers mais en fait il y a
des agneaux et des béliers
mélangés j'aime bien mettre bélier parce
que je sais que les gens aiment pas trop
ont peur qu'il y ait un goût un peu fort
et là ils vont j'espère s'ils arrivent à
se laisser tenter se rendre compte que
quand on nourrit des animaux à l'herbe
sans céréales et ben on nobtient pas ce
mauvais goût que que qu'on retrouve dans
des animaux qui ont mangé beaucoup de
céréales les riettes d'Olivier
marcouillou sont disponibles à la vente
au prix de 8,50 € d'ailleurs saviez-vous
que vous pouviez les acheter en racine
il s'agit d'une monnaie locale et
citoyenne lancée par le Parc naturel
régional de la Haute Vallée de Chevreuse
soutenu par la Ville de Mani lesamo plus
de 500 adhérents l'utilisent déjà et une
centaine de commerçants et
professionnels acceptent les paiements
en racine concrètement comment est-ce
qu'on l'utilise cette monnaie comme
alors en fait il s'agit pas d'une
monnaie mais d'un moyen de paiement
d'accord et donc un billet de banque
c'est un moyen de paiement et ce moyen
de paiement il faut les l'acheter donc
quand vous allez dans un distributeur
vous achetez votre moyen de paiement que
vous payez avec de l'argent que vous
avez en banque bah là c'est exactement
la même chose il va falloir acheter les
billets pour payer ou acheter la réserve
d'argent qu'on va mettre sur son
portefeuille numérique puisqueon on a
maintenant une monnaie numérique on les
achète où les billets alors on les
achète dans ce qu'on appelle des
compteur d'échange qui sont notés sur
une carte interactive sur laquelle il y
a tous les commerces présents
spécifiquement les les les lieux où on
peut avoir ses ces comptoirs d'échange
tous les les commerces sont répertoriés
en terme d'activité
alimentation avec des spécifications et
chacune des chacun des commerces chacun
des professionnels est spécifié de
manière très précise dans son activités
ses horaires et cetera et sa
localisation bien entendu euh une fois
qu'on sait vers qui on veut aller en
fonction de sa proximité ou de son
besoin ben on y va et on peut payer en
racine soit en monnaie papier si c'est
le choix du professionnel
ou en monnaie numérique si c'est son
choix à lui ou en l'un ou l'autre s'il a
accepté de prendre les deux et donc 1 €
é= 1 racine ça se passe com 1 € une
racine ça c'est la loi qui
[Musique]
l'impose
site historique incontournable de manie
lesamo le Musée national de Port Royal
des champs c'est là que se trouent les
ruines de l'abbaye de Port Royal un lieu
fondé au 13e siècle c'est parti je vous
emmène à sa
découverte
[Musique]
et je me trouve justement avec le
directeur du Musée national de Port
Royal des champs Philippe lues bonjour
bonjour Mathilde alors quel est
l'histoire de ce lieu Philippe Luise
c'est une abaye qui a été fondée au 13e
siècle mais elle devient importante au
1e siècle à un moment où la baisse de
Port Royal donc ce sont des femmes
décide euh de faire entrer sa son abaye
dans la Réforme catholique c'est-à-dire
d'en faire une abaye exemplaire elle est
soutenue par la noblesse du pays et elle
devient une abaye extrêmement importante
pendant tout le règne de Louis XI et
donc là aujourd'hui sur ce site il vous
reste quoi principalement des ruines
mais est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer voilà quelles sont ces ruines
oui alors sur le site effectivement il
ne reste que les ruines au niveau de
l'abaye l'abaye a eu eu le malheur de
déplaire au roi Louis XIV par ses choix
religieux par ses choix politiques par
les gens qui la soutenait Louis XIV a
voulu réduire les religieuses à
l'obéissance et puis finalement a obtenu
du pape qu'elle soit chassée et que
l'abaye soit détruite la destruction a
lieu à la fin du règne de Louis XIV elle
est radicale disparition du cloître des
dortoires de l'église il ne reste après
le passage des démolisseurs que les
bâtiments qui servent pour l'agriculture
bien merci beaucoup Philippe lues pour
toutes ces informations merci
[Musique]
beaucoup après cette journée bien
remplie c'est l'heure à présent de
trouver un endroit où dormir et c'est
dans le cœur historique de manilé Ho que
nous avons déniché une maison d'hôte
pleine de charmes Anne Bonassi tient un
git à deux pas de la maison des bonheurs
lieu où a séjourné Auguste bonheur le
frère de Marie Rosalie dite plus
communément Rosa Bonheur peintre
féministe elle fut l'une des premières
femmes à porter un pantalon elle a
également servi de modèles à de
nombreuses artistes féminines la maison
des bonheurs sert aujourd'hui comme lieu
d'exposition et d'animation pour la
commune et c'est donc à quelques mètres
que se trouve la maison prairie bonheur
qui dispose de cinq chambres
[Musique]
doubles et voilà c'est la fin de cette
journée avec nous à Mani lesamo j'espère
qu'elle vous aura plu moi ce que j'ai
préféré c'est le côté rural de la ville
mais aussi son histoire à bientôt sur
tv78 maintenant je vais profiter de la
[Musique]
vue